vous êtes propriétaire de cinq
restaurants à paris vous payez 16000
euros
seize mille euros d isf par on sait ça
avant avant maintenant vous en payer
6000 gens paient 16 1988 l'année
dernière j'en paye 7005 six mille 6000
aujourd'hui 6000 6500 ggg tous vos
chiffres ans est bon alors vous porter
les revendications des gilet jaune
depuis plusieurs années pour une
meilleure répartition des richesses
ça c'est étonnant ces taux n'ont
vraiment c'est un garçon étonnant et
xavier il considère que les riches
devraient payer 45 % d'impôts au delà de
300 mille par an et 50% au-delà de 500
mille euros et votre proposition vous
payez donc blier cfa l'équivalent de
l'ias est maintenant et votre
proposition elle est assez curieuse
parce que vous ne pensez pas à vous mais
vous pensé justement aux français et
vous voudriez quoi alors effectivement
quand des mesures qui peuvent nous
profiter mais son nous paraissent
injustes et contre l'intérêt général
on peut demander des rectifier là je
suis pas forcément un adepte de la sf à
fond la caisse mais je pense que cette
mesure a mal été alors a déjà c'est un
symbole pour la france c'est un symbole
mais surtout à la malle et et je dirais
de transformer en hi-fi c'est à dire que
quelqu'un va rapper se qualifie c'est
l'impôt sur la fortune immobilière et
lord à dire que c'est une mesure de
notre nouveau président d'hockey
emmanuel macron qu'à embellir celle pour
m l'ifi ce ça voilà officiers de 10000
euros pourquoi alors que je veux que je
gagne plus de 500000 euros par an je
vois pas l'intérêt et surtout ce qui se
passe c'est que vous avez un effet alors
on se prive de 3 milliards alors
monsieur mâcon a dit que 7,3 milliards
bon n'avais pas de gilet jaune avait pas
au mieux en vivre après tout bas moi je
suis désolé mais 3 milliards 3 milliards
6 et 3 milliards si regardez par exemple
et je vais vous dire un truc dans les
cantines de france les gens mangent mal
et bien 3 milliards si on mettait déjà
même un milliard dans les cantines
bah je peux vous dire que l'amélioration
de l'assiette et ça serait plus facile
de désir et l'assiette fiscale alors
c'est à dire alors aubrac les mollahs
pour la peau solidarité sur la fortune
qui est anciennement iss est ce qu'un
impôt à payer si votre foyer fiscal
dépassé les 1 million trois cent mille
euros par an liés self rapporté plus de
5 milliards d'euros à l'état est
concerné 375 mille foyers français avec
en 2018 donc emmanuel macron a supprimé
il ya 16 pour le remplacer par l'ifi
donc l'impôt sur la fortune immobilière
et ça concerne donc le patrimoine
immobilier qui dépasse les 1 million
trois cent mille euros alors donc votre
proposition c'est 2 rétablir inscrits
avant la proposition ça vous dérange
alors je fais juste répondre sur deux
points
je me sens très intéressant parce que
vous avez évoqué la question des
cantines et moi je voudrais vous
répondre parce que on a lancé un plan
pauvreté qui fait en sorte que dans les
quartiers prioritaires les quartiers
politique de la ville nadia député
trappe
je crois que tu rappes et concerner un
des petits déjeuners sont gratuits sont
pris en charge pour les enfants à
l'école et 2e ya un deal avec les
mairies pour faire en sorte qu'ils aient
des repas à 1 euro quand la mairie n'a
pas déjà mis en place une tarification
évolutive avec un quotient familial
ça c'est des choses qui sont peu sûres
et on a un vrai problème en france c'est
qu'on a plein plein plein de droit mais
on a un eu recours au droit énorme
donc non je crois qu'on a un travail
aussi à faire là-dessus et christine
kelly qui avait créé sa fondation pour
les mères isolées le sait très bien
on a plein de gens qui ont des droits
mais qui ne les connaissent pas donc ils
font pas appel à ces drames je crois que
c'est aussi un flirt en ligne boonen et
donne un exemple en voilà exemple les
infirmières enfin tout ça voilà un
exemple à donner la vie alors nettement
sur la proposition
madame la mise sur la proposition du
couvent est proposition qu'est-ce que ça
lors la proposition c'est de dire
maintenant aujourd'hui avec l'ifi les
gens qui on avait un patrimoine mobilier
c'est à dire uniquement des actions cela
ne sont plus subtils pour plus d'un
million d'euros cela ne sont plus soumis
à l isf puisque ils ont des actions
alors on nous a dit alors je répète
quand même au début en 2007 sous sarkozy
qu' on avait on devait pas trop faire
payer l'ieseg parce que c'est tel
syndrome vous savez des gens de l'île de
ré qui avait tout d'un coup des terrains
dont on avait dit à l'époque j'avais
votre déposition alors ma proposition
c'est de remonter le financement alors
je peux pas revenir
alors je ne vous je pense qu'il est allé
j'y écrivais votre composition ce qu'il
faut remonter le seuil de déclenchement
de l'isf qui était aujourd'hui d'un
million d'un million 3 à 2 millions 2,2
millions jusqu'à 20 millions vous avez
20 millions vous avez 1%
dean sf et parce que je considère que
les gens qui ont juste une maison c'est
dire que si on travaille et qu'on un
appartement familial une maison
ben je considère qu'ils sont pas c'est
pas des super riches ils ont bossé toute
leur vie ils ont une maison un
appartement famille à paris ses cendres
ça vaut tout de suite un million d'euros
une maison avec cela on les taxe pas
c'est le contraire qu'a fait monsieur
m'a compte puisqu'ils les taxes à partir
de 1 million donc vous voulez le retour
et les sf mais il est trop sur des
tranches plus élevé sur d'étranges plus
élevé est d'accord pour aider prenait 1%
mais attendons c'est pas tout c'est à
dire que on a un bouclier et un plancher
fiscal parce que après tout pourquoi
payer plus de 50% d'impôts donc on a un
bouclier un plancher les gens qui ont
des actions uniquement quand vous avez
plus de 20 millions et si on me dit les
gens qui n'ont pas travaillé parce que
souvent on me dit qu'on le mec il a un
château et des châteaux des biens il n'a
pas travaillé
ouais donc il peut pas payer bien sûr et
c'est ça il allusion il a juste le grill
a juste des biens ouais il n'a pas de
votre avis quant à 20 une longue site
apple les moyens de payer 300 mille
balles de 300000 euros d isf c'est quand
même une truffe donc tu remets au pot et
bien écouter ce qu'ils ont l'air parce
que on a donc on aurait un taux à tous
jusqu'à 100 millions de 2% et on
pourrait hélas il n'y a plus de bouclier
plus de planches et c'est à dire tu
payes ton isf
et la deuxième chose qu'il faut savoir
que le gouvernement qui nous dit juge je
finis le gouvernement qui arrête pas de
nous dire de la valeur travail qui
viennent de mettre en place la flat tax
pour les mêmes gens ça s'appelle des
rentiers cela aujourd'hui avec 30 %
d'impôts il faut savoir que quand vous
avez vous avez lisf vous avez gagné donc
1 ou 2 ou 3 % sur votre essai vous
gagnez 40 entre vous êtes passé 45 ou de
50% d'impôts à 30%
vous avez gagné vous on peut dire que
c'est l'effet jack pas de doute l'effet
jack alors moi j'espère que madame
j'espère que madame la ministre je suis
moi dans les chefs super dur
c'est super important parce qu'il faut
comprendre et derrière c'est des mises à
pied nous a dit j'aimerais j'aimerais
parce que la proposition pas tous en
même temps se calme ça se passe très
bien plus depuis le début juste vous
aviez j'aimerais qu'on résume cette
proposition en une phrase parce que là
avec tous les chiffres
là je vais appeler bertrand renard des
chiffres et des lettres non mais
l'économie ont noté toujours ses phobies
t on peut pas comparer je crois que les
gens boivent non mais leur ai juste en
une phrase emilie qui servent à rien
est-ce que vous pouvez résumer cette
déposition du prado
moi je peux pas la région mais j'ai une
contre-proposition plus globale et plus
simple à faire comprendre lire ça il ya
deux manières de présenter la chose soit
de manière rationnelle on dit est ce que
c'est bon pour le pays parce que les
gens restent en france au lieu de
s'exiler
et puis il ya une manière politique qui
a été catastrophique c'est quand même
temps qu'on annonçait la réforme de 2007
on annonçait la baisse des appels et
l'augmentation de la csg pour les
retraités
donc les gens ça dézingue on l'a dit on
taxe les plus pauvres et un exonère les
plus riches
moi je suis pour une proposition plus
globale je suis pour la remise à plat de
tout ce qui s'apparente et isf pour moi
en étude au le plus tôt la réforme de
l'isf à tout ce qui s'apparente aux
niches fiscales n'examine une paru en
intégrant isf pour savoir si ces niches
fiscales ont une utilité pour le pays ou
pas ou servent simplement à des gens à
économiser un peu d'aidé des impôts une
par une et vous allez voir qu'on va
récupérer pas mal d'argent
ce qu'il ya des dizaines de niches
fiscales dont ni moi ni vous n'avons
entendu parler et qui profite quand même
un tout petit nombre
voilà ça c'est ma proposition alors
j'aimerais qu'on me dise que ce
phénomène parce que j'arrivais à ce que
madame amina doit remettre cette
proposition donc en forme avec voilà ces
tenants et ses aboutissants pourquoi la
propose à nos téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent donc là il ya eu beaucoup de
choses qui ont été dites donc j'aimerais
qu'on résume un petit peu et qu'on
laisse traîner c'est vraiment établir
une vraie proposition alors juste il y à
françois qui est avocat trente deux ans
j'ai les jaunes qui veut réagir sur
cette proposition de l'essai fruits sur
lies parce qu'en réalité je voudrais
dénoncer l'hypocrisie du gouvernement
qui prétend que la réforme qui l'a opéré
par fond de moi j'ai un truc
bienveillance au bout de ce magnifique
sujet trottoir
dites moi je suis bon je suis de votre
côté mais là on est dans la proposition
si on est là pour vraiment non mais je
vais vous expliquer techniquement accord
quoi la réforme qui n'était fait ne
permet absolument pas de favoriser
l'investissement et au contraire c'est
un effet totalement inversé pour une
raison très simple
le patron n'a expliqué qu'avant la
réforme tout le patrimoine mobilier et
tout le patrimoine immobilier étaient
exonérés mais avant la réforme d'ores et
déjà existé une exonération à hauteur de
50% pour toutes les sommes qui
s'investissait dans le capital des pme
si on avait voulu favoriser
l'investissement il aurait fallu porter
cette exonération de 50 à 100 % et là
nous aurions applaudi des deux mains
ce n'est pas ce qui a été fait ce qui a
été fait c'est d'exonérer l'ensemble du
patrimoine mobilier c'est à dire les
actions mais aussi des épargnes si bien
qu'aujourd'hui il est très très fortunés
n'ont plus besoin d'investir dans le
capital des pme parce qu'ils sont de
droit et de fait exonérer est donc cet
argent ils le placent plutôt dans la
sphère financière fessard des situations
de rente et non de l'argent ne trouve
plus à s'investir avec une exonération à
100 % pour les pme quelle serait votre
position au volant mais à rétablir les
sf mais avec une exonération à 160 pour
les personnes qui s'investissent dans
l'objectif des filles alors parce qu'il
faut qu'on formule la proposition moi je
suis pas d'accord bernard laporte weedon
je suis pas d'accord dans le cas de
daniel effectivement daniel y verser un
restaurant à paris peut pas partir pas
partie de vivo portugais a signé david
et xavier mais fois parts et daniela
aussi en partie revenu en belgique de
tirer store et chaud la part de gens
sont partis parce qu'ils ont passé leur
métier leur cas mais regardez fortunés
ici combien de jeunes sont parmi cent
par an sur 350 mais je sais par deux
examens sans papa coach a beaucoup
entendu parler japonais qui sont parties
d'accord sur tout le temps à l'époque
hollande est soigné pour ça ils sont
partis alors moi je suis moi je propose
et je vais dans le simple c'est
tellement du maquereau il a pris cette
décision en pensant que les gens
allaient revenir soit disant que
certains reviennent et encore je dis
bien sous 10 à moi je ne suis pas c'est
qu'on est sûr paul disent que certains
reviennent pour investir mais attend
donc deux hommes de regarder si ça se
fume ça s'est pas fait c'est encore une
fois et si ça se fait pas attention
voilà il faudra qu'il prenne une autre
sur le terrain c'est déjà mes confères
fiscaliste m'indique que il est avocat
très bien et désormais les
investissements se sont effondrés parce
que les gens n'ont plus besoin alors il
ya un deuxième effet kiss cool c'est que
l'impact de
il y avait cette exonération bénéficier
aussi pour les dons aux associations
ouais ouais c'est ça aux associations se
sont effondrés oui alors ils en ont que
je puisse avoir l'éclairage de la
députée qui a voté cette loi exige
d'ailleurs non seulement j'ai voté cette
loi je les portais même dans ma campagne
législative parce que voilà on y croit
et je suis commissaire aux finances et
je suis là députés qui siègent dans le
comité de suivi de la réforme de la
fiscalité du patrimoine
donc ça concerne isf ça concerne le
prélèvement fiscal unique dont nous a
parlé monsieur que ça concerne la baisse
de l'impôt sur les sociétés vous avez
dit vraiment beaucoup de choses mais ce
que je veux et je vais pas pouvoir tous
les reprendre une à une mais je tiens je
me tiens à votre disposition pour le
faire mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que la première réunion de ce
comité s'est tenue en décembre et la
première chose qu on s'est dit c'est
qu'il allait difficile de l'évaluer en
si peu de temps c'est à dire qu'on nous
demandait des premiers résultats pour
septembre 2019
pourquoi parce qu'il ya un certain il
faut avoir une convergence de données
qu'ils sont que cette mesure est
efficace ou pas je veux juste revenir
sur le fait de pourquoi nous y avons cru
et pourquoi nous avons supprimé les
serbes voulaient oui parce que vannes où
les rosiers crimen pour ce début ce que
tous m'ont dit que les plus fortunés
n'allez plus partir et elle y revenir en
france mais parce que tout simplement
nous croyons que le l'investissement qui
se fait donc l'investissement dit
productifs qui va sur le financement des
entreprises et pas forcément les plus
grosses entreprises je parle des des pme
je parle des dépôts des start up des
petites entreprises qui naissent comme
ça de la création d'entreprise est bien
sont conditionnés à l'un des salons les
pme mais lisf pme dont vous parlez n'a
plus lieu d'être puisque de toute façon
l avantage fiscal qui existait par
rapport à ça n'est plus adossé à l'impôt
bah oui donc mémoriser ce que vous avez
dit quelque chose qui n'est pas tout à
fait exact quand vous avez dit les
investissements dans les entreprises se
sont effondrés clé la réalité c'est
qu'on a plus de 10 milliards de leurs
investissements qui ont été faits sur
2018 mais c'est déjà bien donc il faut
savoir la vérité
monsieur chichi qui a parlé des
investissements étrangers des personnes
qui partent s'établir à l'étranger
il se trouve que j'ai travaillé dans une
banque et effectivement des personnes
qui partent s'installer à l'étranger il
y en a beaucoup
parce que nous taxons en france nous
sommes les champions du monde des
prélèvements obligatoires qualité est ce
que est ce que juste petite question est
ce que vous voyez des résultats sur
cette suppression de l' iss courrier des
gens revenir
est ce que vous voyez des gens investir
est ce que vous voyez de moins de gens
partira lorsque vous dire cyril c'est
que nous sommes en relation permanente
avec les institutions financières les
assureurs pour évaluer cette réforme
donc nous sommes un certain enfin un
nombre de parlementaires à suivre cela
si ça marche ça on modifiera si ça lui
vaut laisser le temps de l'évaluation
dans le mien en tout cas les points les
plus loin les indicateurs de confiance
sont là ils sont au rendez vous qu'ils
soient des investisseurs étrangers
qu'ils soient des investisseurs ou des
épargnants en france les indicateurs de
confiance sont bons et ce sont des actes
dicateur à prendre au sérieux alors
j'aimerais donc j'aimerais j'aimerais
lacombe est en forme c'est la
proposition je veux dogs à des
conditions différentes de l'utilité de
tous les cas du risque aux réformes de
l'usf conflit pardon juste sur les
niches sur les niches fiscales vous avez
relevé un vrai vrai sujet sur lequel
nous sommes en train de travailler pour
ça comme une autre dimension à remettre
à plat toutes les niches fiscales c'est
qu'ils ne produisent pas les effets
escomptés ce qui aujourd'hui polluent
notre économie mais bien cela nous nous
travaillons je voulais vous dire c'est
uniquement si c'est investir en capital
des pleurs alors qu'elle est sûre il
sait ça fait alors là c'est la
proposition ou non qu'on mette enfin la
proposition écart ou les cadeaux faits
de l'utilité de tous les cadeaux fiscaux
réforme de l'usf comprise toit plat
automatismes madame la députée le nom on
examine temps de rétablissement de l'isf
avec une exonération 100% sur les pme et
pourquoi pas le alors on a
d'augmentation fond en larmes en général
ward joue pas tout seul sur la fortune
on a deux propositions là en fait on a
une il y en a eu évidemment ciblées sur
l' isf et j'entends la proposition
oui et de rétablir ou de remettre et une
eau sur les détails sur les niches
visées mal elle éveille aussi l'esprit
la remise à plat des cadeaux fiscaux
incluant lien certes on a deux choses
dont karim djellabi est ce que les
témoins soient dans leur madone l'a fait
tout alla des ministres intégrons
peut-être l'esprit qui était proposée
par notre jeune avocat de normandie de
qui consiste à dire les les gens
modestes ont des droits et des devoirs
les politiques le rappelle souvent les
gens qui ont de l'argent aussi des
droits et des devoirs
quand on fait un cadeau fiscal quant au
fait un allègement fiscal on va pas dire
qu'ado il faut qu'il soit conditionnée
par une contrepartie qui soit une
obligation c'est pas si vous avez envie
vous investissiez il faut que nous ayons
une contrepartie obligatoire
[Applaudissements]
vous savez quand on dit ils vont partir
faut arrêter avec ça on dit aux pauvres
gens la phrase tu aimes ou tu la quittes
faut dire aux riches
la france tu l'aimés ou tu la quittes
[Applaudissements]
la députée oui répondent non sur glace
vous voulez vraiment de d'afficher un
slogan digne d'une grande campagne ça se
passait très bien jusqu'à présent
j'aimerais qu'on vienne dans le dialogue
et non mais on avance sur les prévisions
la bonne chose c'est le président l'a
dit il va voir si ça marche pas comme
dit karim si lui il espère encore une
fois que ça revienne etc il va vite voir
au bout de la ville et ça c'est pas le 6
mois mais ça va sur un peu comme si
l'économie redémarre les plus riches
investissent sont venus créer du capital
et à mieux si ça se fait pas et mme
effectivement mais chez vous n'avez pas
rempli vos devoirs
donc on arrête et on remet pas bien ses
fils âgés mais c'est son droit mais les
résultats ne sont pas d'opposition
est-ce que vous pouvez nous résumer sa
valeur on a une proposition ciblée sur
l' isf qui seraient en gros pour établir
les acef et une proposition qui est
remise à plat et examens l'utilité de
toutes les niches fiscales on a deux
propositions relief avec exonération
sans pourra pour cela c'est un tout
petit peu plus loin sa part entre 1 280
caractère pour ne pas mixer sur tout
suspect mais pour cent comme ça on se
retrouvait on y est je suis en train de
le faire aux régies on vous fait les
deux propositions nous dit si vous
trouvez que c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise idée